[Music]
welcome to the plastic pills podcast
episode 148 at least of the pill pod
episodes I am your host pills joined by
my co-hosts
Victor yes Eric hello good job guys
we're getting this in
148 and some episodes in and we are
getting getting the intros down yeah I
think you could just record that one and
replay it every time that was good all
right so we have been dealing with
stupid prefixes to academic words and
continuing with our tradition finished
off metamodernism now we're doing
anti-philosophy which I felt was much
less much less uh flipp it and stupid
but before we get to anti philosophy
proper I wanted to say I went down
another small Rabbit Hole reading stuff
for this episode cuz I kept getting
recommended clicks and there's just so
many of these we we maybe a whole
episode or a whole series of episodes
could be done I'm not saying we'll do it
but it could be done on these manifestos
and godamn just like calls for the
renewal of humanities or the renewal of
the discipline or the renewal of
philosophy
to recover some old greatness that we've
lost the recovery of systems building
another one but people have been writing
this [__] for like 150 years I think it
started probably with make theology
great again so why are they saying this
no one's listening do you think some
University president who is who became
the University president so they can
hire their brother's construction
company to build the new basketball
stadium do you think they're reading
your call for the renewal of the
humanities
absolutely that was very specific well
have the humanity has been been crushed
like I don't know like is it I like
that's another thing that I'm not so
sure about like like these rumors of its
decline in the University like I guess
there's some truth to it but I also feel
like often those those are like a little
over um exaggerated I think uh funding
has been drastically cut enrollment is
very
low and a lot of the if we're talking
anti-philosophy that's stuff that
responds to what's going on now and a
lot of these manifestos now usually cite
um you know stem the promotion of stem
above and beyond any other discipline
like Obama has said it presidents say it
you know stem is the most important
thing we got to invest in stem and
wasn't this though like a a cold war
policy and the other thing would be the
neoliberalization ation of the
universities the humanities is a is a
quote unquote useless discipline
philosophy is
non-instrumental and so it tends not to
attract investment on its own I know
that that's what people say but I don't
think it's true uh like like at least
not the extent to which so there's
actually a book
um about getting work in the academic
job market that came out maybe
um a few years ago called good work if
you can get it and he actually like goes
through a bunch of the stats on
this um where is it and uh like it seems
like like it's a lot of it's like really
overblown like when you actually look at
the enrollment numbers so this book was
published in let's see here 20 like I I
understand the reasoning of what you're
saying like it kind of makes sense but
when you actually look at the number
2020 but like he has a lot of really
persuasive things to say like people say
this right there's like this feeling
they're like oh like people are
encouraging stem they're paying lip
service when you actually look at the
numbers in terms of enrollment and like
money that different departments get
it's actually not true like I think
there's like a really interesting stat
about how English departments actually
get
like uh like kind of a shot like the
amount of money that they spend per grad
student or something like that is
actually like a lot like more than uh
than like science stem grad students oh
you're going to bring numbers into
it I don't know what metrics you're
looking at that sounds like a per capita
funding but at least the
opening uh please defer of this article
that I was looking at says basically
since 2007 enrollment in both history
and English is down pretty much
50% which is pretty huge for less than
20 years I mean that's that's the type
of kind of position you hear you know
like because obviously that goes against
so many things I've read by academics
and so much of what I've see on the news
and I see this truth of that stem is
promoted and the humanities are
not but I mean I've heard stats that go
for the Humanity's in Decline argument
and for the reasons now I mean it's
always seems like it's in crisis but I
mean for the the reasons and the Pres I
mean that's what I've always heard
though I've always heard that that that
narrative right but I mean yeah it's a
it's a kind of opens up the Temptation
for a skeptical position oh the
humanities are I would say that they're
not in trouble but they're not that's
like oh really so do that just mean
they're they're intrinsically less
valuable or or there's just nothing
wrong with them and all this is kind of
just weird over a hundred years ago hurl
wrote the same book that philosophy
matters actually actually
philosophy if you're doing science then
you need to be doing philosophy first
because if you're doing science you
actually have a philosophy even if you
don't recognize it that it just has
perpetually a reputation for being in
crisis without being in crisis it seems
to me like it's kind of in crisis it
seems like it's kind of useless
otherwise there wouldn't be so many
calls I guess for how to renew it on
every person's idiosyncratic personal
program that they want to save
everything by propagating it's
interesting but it seems like a
contrarian perspective yeah it I mean I
agree I I I was I was genuinely
surprised when I read it because because
I wasn't reading the book for that
reason like I'm because I'm I'm on the
academic job market right now so I was
genuinely like reading it like for
advice regarding that and then I was
surprised when I came across that
section well Badu wrote a Manifesto for
philosophy which was kind of a thing
in the 80s and and 90s they came back
yeah the manifestos are the modernist
things well delz wrote what his philos
what is philosophy book also I although
Badu is very much he's not very romantic
about it um he's not doing a renew in
the way that these annoying articles
keep trying to do a renew he's kind of
saying philosophy has always had a very
specific job and we should stop calling
anti-philosophy philosophy so welcome to
the anti- philosophy episode seems like
he's still committed as a philosopher
though but he thinks anti- philosophy is
like also important and don't be the
wrong kind of philosopher like delz cuz
delz is a philosopher of the one which
is a a bad thing
says logic of Worlds the one the
multiple I think my hypothesis is better
that philosophy has always been
self-help and people didn't want to
recognize it as such and then when we
actually got a self-help industry
created in large part by like post
hippies and Oprah then philosophy didn't
really have a job anymore so all these
calls to renew are trying to figure out
what philosophy's job actually is and
finding out that it's kind of extraneous
yes it's a a little bit of a luxury that
you dabble in on the side which is just
a repeat like of of her's complaint it's
a disciplinary specialization and then
going well what the hell am I for yeah I
say I say on a philosophy podcast yeah
one of the worst things that can happen
to a
philosophical Enterprise is that it
become institutionalized and caught up
in the disciplinary structure of
knowledge
he says its absorption or incorporation
into academic knowledge as the worst
possible risk for the fate of their
discipline so the professionalization of
philosophy yeah
institutionalization professionalization
yeah yeah I mean it's always had
knowledge for knowledge's sake science
philosophy and then for the betterment
of
humankind seems to me it's been torn
between those two goals well I don't
don't think any of us would be called
philosophers right in his sense in his
uh idiosyncratic definition reinscribing
the boundaries of what philosophy is and
is not well it depends like what are the
the philosophers to the anti
philosophers as we said all the we went
over these examples you know like if
dayart is a philosopher then Pascal was
the anti- philosopher if the uh I guess
the encyclopedists like uh
dero uh were uh philosophers than
Russo's anti- philosopher you know
permen hertis anti
philosopher so I guess it depends are
you a Parmenides a
dayart n anti philosopher laon anti
philosopher VI philosopher kard anti
philosopher right are you a Hegel this
is such a stupid divide when he lines it
up like this I'm like all the good ones
of the anti philosophers anyway they get
all the best I'll just go over to that
site it's like the best rock stars are
all in hell yeah this is a stupid
Division I think ultimately my view is
there's like this is a madeup
distinction I think they're all
philosophers I think like philosophy is
simply always in the business of all
distinctions are made up no no I don't I
think that this is just a useless
distinction like it's it's really like I
mean be it I think it's a it's a useless
distinction because I think it's
misleading it makes it sound like what
they're trying to do is more radical
than I think it actually is I think that
philosophy has always been in the
business of undermining views that came
before them I think this is totally in
in the business of that I think you know
nich is kind of a a hyper modernist in a
way by like taking the the insights from
modernity and and and pushing them
Beyond I just don't think that uh I
think it's misleading to say it's
anti-philosophy because it makes it
sound like it's something different and
I think ultimately they're doing the
same thing they're doing a radical form
of questioning
um that is welcome in philosophy and I I
agree I tend to prefer in many cases the
anti- philosophers I just think this is
a stupid madeup distinction that that is
misleading they're all philosophers well
well to you have to read Badu in his own
terms though because he gives specific
qualifications for what he means by
philosophy versus non-philosophy yeah
there's like metaphysics basically right
it's like yeah people who are trying to
find metaphysics and people who reject
it no no I wouldn't say that it's not
really to do with metaphysics it's to do
with his uh
definition of truth because the
philosopher someone who uses a truth
procedure that is particular to
philosophy as opposed to an anti-
philosopher who you put some other
Endeavor above philosophy whether that's
Aesthetics or
politics and the truth procedure then is
less important than their other Endeavor
or their other ultimate goal I think you
can say in the case of nche this would
be an aesthetic goal yeah it's it's more
like um it is what you were saying anti
philosophy he's he's naming it almost as
a separate tradition so you're right
like he's separating it from philosophy
what you're saying is philosophy's own
willingness you know you you were
announcing it in the kind of
Enlightenment wet dream way where it's
like self-correcting Enterprise but he's
separating the anti philosophy so yeah
it's more of a gesture in that way but
it's still this kind of you know
antagonist agonistic relationship you
have I agree I mean it's it's reacting
to a certain way of doing philosophy
anti philosophers question the
fundamentals and the foundations and the
value of philosophy as an Enterprise the
most philosophical thing to do which is
like a challenge yeah there you go well
I mean he's giving it a different name
you you understand though he's not being
diminutive of anti-philosophy he says
like philosophy has to contend with laon
if philosophy is going to be anything
ever yeah yeah for sure yeah like it's
provocative and it's supposed to be
something beneficial to philosophy if
philosophy can sort of meet the
challenge and not
aify as it as it does and say academic
structures I guess yeah I mean I don't
disagree with like the basics of what
he's saying I just think it's a I just
think like the term itself I've got to
quibble more with the term I think it's
misleading but I understand what he
saying I think it's like his take on
this too it's like him forging a unique
take on this subject too
so yeah like I wouldn't use his term
maybe but I think it's an interesting
suggestion to give it its own name if we
take it like this for example uh the
truth procedure which is pretty Central
we we we've talked about Badu I think
only once on this podcast before and it
was in the context of communism because
communism is a truth or a kind of event
but we we have like huro and haiger and
bedu and they all or early haiger I
should I should say but they want
philosophy to be a kind of
procedure for hural it's seeking the
transcendental ground from which to
observe whatever else including
science uh haiger is asking the question
of being and for Badu it's not confusing
these truth procedures with other
procedures that kind of look like truth
procedures so what an philosopher does
is instead of saying philosophy is the
the highest truth procedure they kind of
put something else in its place whether
it's Aesthetics or politics so he wants
to very very narrowly I guess you'd say
very narrowly Define philosophy from
these things that really look very close
to it some of the ways he was
characterizing it too reminded me of our
our [__] episode right he's what he
what beer was calling Dangerous Minds or
this is the anti- philosophers is at
least for N I guess that could extend to
the others too but yeah Dangerous Minds
would you make that comparison though
because because [__] was just saying
they're dangerous because you're
18-year-old nephew might turn into a
fascist if he reads them yeah because I
don't think because [__] [__] I
don't think has a problem in principle
with yeah yeah I mean it has a different
political thrust yeah it has a different
political thrust but that's really his
concern I don't think his concern has
much to do with like questions of how
the philosophy is being done he's not
interested in like the at least in that
characterization he's not interested in
the ideas but in their consequences but
can I say here like a little bit this uh
Western chauvinism point which I don't
like to make very often because it's
kind of a cheap point but it's almost
saying there's this definition of
philosophy and that it's almost not
contingent that it's just based on these
truth procedures that it appeared
suddenly from nowhere and I might be an
anti- philosopher for drawing attention
to it but we we read an
axamer and
anaximander is a philosopher but we read
how difficult it is to distinguish what
he's saying from the mythological
literature of the time and then you have
got like I don't know stuff I don't know
anything about but Indian philosophy the
Buddha dosm even ancient EGP Egypt where
the Greeks were saying like straight up
we got all this [__] from ancient Egypt
so I don't know how you separate like
Plato all of a sudden from the sort of
wisdom life literature you know you
follow the teachings isn't this
hardboiled truth concept relatively late
in the game of what we'd call
philosophy because like like I said with
an ax amender that we just read
philosophy is basically
indistinguishable from
something you'd call wisdom teaching one
thing I one interesting way I guess we
can start looking at characteristics of
anti- philosophers right and anti-
philosophers put the philosophizing
aside and they supposedly embody what
philosophy is supposed to be talking
about so somebody like Socrates right
who was just relentlessly questioning
and never wrote anything you know at
least Plato's Socrates right Plato's
presenting Socrates as the person who
almost like
embodies the values of philosophy and
then Plato's just kind of writing about
them as you know or somebody like you
know sleeping by the market so they can
be so like living the principles of
philosophy even like n right like like
fashioning your life as a work of art
like as we were talking about last time
like consciously and affirmatively
overcoming the kind of like or at least
doing that eternal return of the same
experiment whenever you make a kind of
decision you have to encounter that
impossibility of of affirming it for
it's all eternity or something like it's
a very effusive and now nness kind of
thing as well to be an anti- philosopher
in relationship to philosophy yeah but
you like by making all these definitions
here's the boundary here's the marked
space there's the unmarked space and we
have marked space competing with each
other but use the kind of dude that like
if you're hearing this and you're
wondering if you need to buy in you kind
of need to buy in completely I'd say you
need to be struck by this project and
then accept it and then if you don't
you're not going to find much use for it
like I was immediately put off
personally because the first things I
read from Badu were about math and how
math is this
transcendental I don't even know how to
call It's It deals with ontology
apparently and I find math hard
ontological set theory yes I find math
hard and therefore I dislike it and then
the other thing he talks about all the
time is religion which I find tedious
and arbitrary so I was just put off by
it at the start but if you do like math
stuff and uh truth stuff truth I guess
this is for you you know Al Alan Soo on
Alan soal weighed in on Badu and said
that his interpretation of set theory
was quote unquote
Preposterous so I don't know if Alan
soall is the guy to be listening to on
this well set theory has been as as
we've seen I think set theory has been
embattled almost since its beginning so
it's not surprising that so-call would
Channel intuitionism and Bash it
but set theory I mean it's uh it it
really reminded me of of what he was
talking about in the um Vicken Stein
anti as an anti- philosopher but among
philosophers some of them are anti-
philosophers and they kind of remind
philosophy of various things that it
might be in danger of missing well we
can say about Badu to Briefly summarize
where he stands um he contemporaries
with you know the dill dillas wrote a
book on dillas that is not very good but
contemporaries with aler or student of
aler and was a reader of laon he was a
militant
maist for the 70s and 80s and he's
committed unlike those contemporaries he
really wants like a position for truth
and to get to what Badu mean means by
truth is I think kind of important to to
start with because it defines philosophy
so the truth is not is universal and
it's
abstract but it
is contemporaneous or it arrives with
events so he's got this book the main
main claim to fame I'd say is being an
event and events evolve or they produce
subjects and they produce truths and
they're not really seen as possible
before occurring so they they from
nothing
erupt and then the job of the subject is
to commit to events the main one being
revolution in an abstract sense whatever
Revolution you could think of like a
Christianity even as being revolutionary
so it's it's not possible the French
Revolution it's not possible at one
point in time and then after the fact it
kind of defines
the an entire discourse an entire
procedure that comes after it and this
Fidelity to the event it's very
temporal but it's not it's not truth in
the way that we would use truth to say
something like oh it's just a name for
everything that is truth is kind of a
production or an
eruption yeah that was an interesting
point and philosophers remain committed
to this while anti philos opers they
want to suture is his term for it but
they want to like uh graft it off into
into minor discourses they want to talk
about Aesthetics so they want to talk
about politics instead of this uh narrow
commitment to the truth oh yeah yeah
like cutting off the king's head is an
event that's like in principle
impossible he points to these like very
extreme things like U or like a Stalin
istic kind of imposition or a ban right
like it's something that's supposed to
be by definition
impossible it's makes it an event like
no one could imagine
it yeah like the conditions the
conditions of possibility were sort of
impossible until they're revealed you
know they would they would prescribe
that
act right and and I think anti-
philosophy is there to remind philosop
of the ACT which is opposed which is
which is not the proposition it's like
radically opposed to the philosophical
proposition so when we say philosophy is
is inscribed in that history of truth
that you're talking about all of
philosophy is inscribed in it and
anti-philosophy sort of flips the flips
the
um um the that value binary there I
guess and moves truth out of the
privileged
position in various ways like with n
right truth is just the mobile Army of
metaphors momies and anthropomorphisms
it like radically subverts
Philosophy from the perspective of of
now he says there's two things that it
reminds philosophy of the conditions of
philosophy which are always contemporary
with it those the conditions of
philosophy are always
contemporary it's a confusion
of their own time that philosophers
construct new Concepts I had a bit of
trouble with this definition because I
don't really get what the
eternality bit is adding to truth you
know truths are
Eternal because they are like
historically contingent but their
historical contingency points also to
their universality but the universality
is only known
anachronistically so it seems like the
question of epistemology here maybe I'm
misreading it I don't know but the
question of epistemology is being all
lighted here where the thing is just
being declared Eternal abstract
Universal despite the fact that it
occurs in the event and then you can
only name it that stuff after the fact
it seems like you don't need do both at
the same time why you just call the
thing contingent I guess if you if you
believe it to be contingent then you're
less likely to be faithful and to commit
to it but
then I don't know is it is it Eternal or
is it just a matter of belief in the
truths
eternality well the way I gathered it
from the I mean it takes a lot in the
vicenin anti-philosophy book right
that's there's a distinction between
substance and
world right the world is where things
happen but philosophers use proposition
to describe substance what is possible
what what could possibly
happen and when we describe any State of
Affairs it's what could possibly happen
and it's Eternal right possibility is a
possibility if it does happen it means
it was always
possible um but that possibility depends
on actualization in the world so you
have that substance Eternal
possibilities actual in the world
where sense points to the world oh so
the eternality points to the substance
not okay that's liit isn't it yeah oh I
didn't read it that way that makes sense
though
neat how would you characterize in this
kind of
division uh like where would you put set
theory or sorry not set theory um uh
sorry systems theory on the side of well
possibility ities but I think it pays
very close attention to the
actualization of
possibilities seeing those two things
you know the the operation of a system
but do you think systems theory is
trying to do metaphysics it's kind of an
anti-philosophy in a way I think yeah
systems theory is not concerned with a
truth procedure it's concerned with
procedure itself so I guess in that way
it's not
philosophy but Victor I want to ask you
said this is this just metaphysics that
he's arguing is philosophy do you think
that he's arguing for metaphysics
specifically as philosophy uh yeah I
mean I think that there's like a it
seems like he's trying to say that
there's like a certain kind of Hunt For
Truth is like real philosophy I guess or
like traditional philosophy and then
those that question that uh I guess
truth procedure I mean I only read the
short piece so like a lot of the stuff
you guys are saying like I don't know
because I haven't done any serious
reading on Badu but that's what it
sounded like at least in the sh piece
yeah like anti- philosophy kind of
questions those the basic orientation of
philosophy
and and yeah it reminds it of the two
things I mentioned like you know the
conditions of doing philosophy are
always now and contemporary and that the
philosophy speaks from a place of of um
Authority privileged pace of authority
has to remind philosophy of that lest
they forget the Contemporary and the
authority of the voice
conditions this is what I liked most
about bad you and I still find it like I
find it kind of inspiring is that like
unlike some sort of additive discourse
of Truth to get a whole bunch of
different tests done in different places
to come up with a final answer his
version of Truth is always condition
dependent so philosophy in any event or
post any event and there are very few
events by the way we should we should uh
suggest that events are very rare but
when they happen they happen
explosively but I I really like his
description of philosophy as being this
very contained answer to certain events
as rare as they are so this is why you
can never come up with like a sum tootal
truth if you align up all the
propositions that have made through
history from Plato to
rouso wait is rouso a philosopher or an
anti- philosopher he's an anti-
philosopher he's anti yeah okay so we'll
go with Montana or something if we if we
add up these these
discreet um approbations of Truth we're
never going to get to a sum total which
is why philosophy has a different
purpose in any situation and I kind of
like that I kind of uh buy that that
it's very much processual and context
dependent but I can't really I'm having
a hard time grasping what he means by
the universality which is in some way
connected to set theory which I don't
get but there's a nothing and the
nothing is supposedly this I can't even
say ground it's a less than a ground
where these procedures are supposed to
be arriving from and it kind of I don't
know it sounds like he's trying to Hitch
his hitch his wagon to the the
mathematics train just because
mathematics is uh a little bit more
reliable than the contingent historical
conditions that produce philosophy and I
don't I kind of don't know why he's
doing that but all again I'm too dumb to
understand math so maybe that's why I
get I really see it in the in the Vicken
Stein book why he's hitching it to that
wagon right cuz you know set the theory
was at the basis of you know formalizing
mathematics that was the point of set
theory was kind of like um you know
mathematical symbolism and coming up
with the basic sets of statements that
all mathematics is engaging in and
symbolizing them and and and then
figuring out the basic the basic
propositions or axioms upon which like a
consistent and complete mathematical you
know that holds like pre Goodell's
incompleteness theorem stuff and um you
know the tractatus is in that tradition
of of logical positivism so I can see
why that stuff is relevant here don't
see it so much in yeah like N I found
out his dad was a mathematician well
that makes sense yeah there you go maybe
he's trying to make his dad happy by
reincorporating mathematics into
philosophy
but no like you'd expect or at least I
totally expected on reading this Vicken
Stein thing that he's going to be going
after the late Vicken Stein when he's
like talking about uh language games and
all that stuff but no he goes after yeah
the tractatus the uh analytical magnum
opus of Vicken Stein's tractatus which
I've never read I never will read but
Eric can you explain a little more what
like what why is Vicken Stein at his
most
procedural why is that anti- philosophy
yeah bad is pretty clear about this
saying yeah the tractatus is the one
work I'm going to deal with here it's
the only thing he thought was fit to be
published the you know the the the
fundamental insights he comes to with
this book are muddled and sort of he
goes off them by the philosophical yeah
he's he's very uh by the investigations
yeah he's he's very adamant that what
what Vicken Stein formulates in the
tractatus which is again like you know
Vicken Stein is a huge fan of Fraga he
even sent this manuscript to him when
Fraga was completely baffled I think and
uh and he worked with bertran Russell
too who whose sort of logical atomism is
is what Vicken Stein inherited in this
text it's the adamism so the the adamism
is is about getting down to the bottom
the basic statements again right like I
was saying that that you can sort of
formalize a language with but obviously
he's got very different aims than that
sort of mathematical logic project and
just for clarity sake by atomism you
mean the the value of propositions in
logic right yeah like analyzing
propositions down to their Atomic
elements basically which means you know
I think in in terms it's in in the terms
of that text it's objects you know
propositions contain terms and terms are
objects and the names for objects and so
the smallest sort of atom is is a
valueless object that gets sort of
combined up in propositions then
propositions are you know facts saying
statements of fact sayings of facts I'm
having nightmare from uh taking symbolic
logic yeah it's why Vicken Stein is so
quotable too because it's all just like
very apped aidic statements
and axioms and very almost like nian
aphoristic style too so he's very
strange in his style and Vicken Stein
style is very unique and strange but
throughout this process the reason that
the Vicken Stein of the tractatus and
I'm s this like I really apologize to
the lat listeners this is not an easy
listening episode but the the Vicken
Stein of the tractatus is Accused here
of not being committed to truth but
rather being committed to sense and
sense in the sense of the propositions
as their own system as opposed to what
Badu is calling truth which is not the
logical truth right because the logical
truth here would be the sense making the
sense making through propositions which
is something that the later Vicken Stein
said I'm quitting that [__]
anyway but when we talk about sense
instead of truth then we're actually
combining like uh two former senses of
what we would call truth truth meaning
the thing that is true for all time if
things are as they are then we can use
propositions to describe them they can
be true or false which is they make
sense and the reason Badu turns on this
is saying we don't want sense from
propositions we want truth from
propositions So Def despite the fact
that this is considered by um the
analytic Tradition at least Bertrand
Russell at the time to be one of the
greatest texts ever written but je is
going to take issue with it and that
it's it's distracting you could say or
it's uh it's not furthering the cause of
truth it's furthering the cause of sense
making in language which speaks to his
more broad term in terms turn in terms
of his peers and his contemporaries he's
not interested in this linguistic [__]
he wants to go to a different level the
the procedural production of events
rather than whether language makes sense
or not yeah I think and I think it's
obvious from Vicken Stein's very you
know we we've probably heard a lot of
sound bites of his very like sort of
hostile statements towards philosophy
like nonsense it's all nonsense and
babble but this all comes later right I
think there's some of that in this as
well there's some of that in the
tractatus as well one of the first
quotes what is it most of the
propositions and questions to be found
in philosophical works are not false but
nonsensical that's one of the first
quotes that badya drops from Vick sign
into his text here so most are
nonsensical so how does
philosophy produce this nonsense and
then locating that nonsense that
Babble is actually what the
expansiveness like that's that operation
that anti-philosophy is supposed to
perform it's like I think if it is a det
totalizing and he divides it into three
operations and says can we find these
three sort of DET totalizing operations
in vict Stein's U well let's look in the
tractatus we'd best find it
there and there's sort of three
operations that constitute
antiphilosophy and it's challenge to
philosophy at least badia thinks he sort
of distilled these three operations that
anti- philosophy performs and he's going
to find them now in Vicken Stein's
tractatus and so it's a PR yeah there's
a lot they're complicated operations
they're not for listing yeah this is not
this is not easy listening um Bruno
Bruno buels writes like an introduction
that's basically as long as the book
it's huge but if we leave Vicken Stein
aside for a second because we're playing
way too much inside baseball I guess
what these anti- philosophers do is say
philosophy in our time is doing this one
thing and that's all [__] it's based
on uh shifting
foundations Maybe dareda for our
listeners might be a better example well
he sees sophistry as an example of
anti-philosophy right sophistry like
like you know just fullon no that's not
true adopting he splits he splits
sophistry from anti-philosophy sophistry
is just fake well they might use the
resources I guess it's more like like he
says anti-philosophy might delve into
the resources that sophistic exploit as
well right so it's that this this idea I
mean the nich's idea of overturning of
all values that would be like an anti
that would be like an anti-philosophical
kind of statement there or us using
sophistic the sophists they just deal in
doxa which is opinion and it has no
relation to the truth whatsoever but the
anti- philosophers are more advanced
than that in that they attack philosophy
supposed truth procedure fees so they
are much more credible opponent like
diogenes is a more credible opponent
than the the other sophists yeah like a
Socratic questioning I guess would be
more a better example well for example
he also says that the tractatus is
anti-philosophy but that late Vicken
Stein so the investigations descended
into sophistry yeah that would be like
an anti-philosophical
operation I mean this seems all very
exciting but like like I said before you
have to really you have to really buy
into this project to
really F or get anything out of it yeah
it is
destructive it goes on to what is a
truth procedure or or things like that
this is unfolding it unfolds in four
stages you have nomination which is to
name the disruption then it intervenes
then you have to pay for de Fidelity to
it and then you have to force it to be
discussed so at any point along the line
if you have a problem with his
terminology and his laying out of these
procedures which you may or may not but
in in the same way that uh haiger lays
out an existential analytic if at any
point you want to jump off and do
something different or bring something
else in then it just seems like you lose
the point of the project you don't need
to
decide what fits and what doesn't fit
because he's just going to tell you
before you even
start maybe that makes me an anti
philosopher which is a label I'd be
proud to uh burden myself with yeah I
think like just radically questioning
like when we say things like what what
uses philosophy you know ideas who cares
kind of stuff right like
that appropriately done that can be like
an anti- philosophical kind of project
is to sort of really radically Challenge
and say you know how is this helping but
like anti-philosophy is is almost like
an inversion you know it's very
individualistic like n it's very anti
philosophy like it's very much concerned
with challenging philosophy it's so
here's an example you have laon right
laon subject Lon subject decentered
split its desire is its desire but it's
also the desire of the other so it's not
contained it's not identified as a thing
this presents a huge problem for
philosophy but in a good way like you
have to be able to answer laon's subject
with a philosophical subject in order
for philosophy to be relevant at all and
he does this he says instead of you know
the subject of who the [__] ever Kant or
dayart we don't need that subject
because our subject has to answer today
and his example of this is the subject
is it's not permanent it's not Eternal
it's nothing like that but it's created
in response to the
event so it's a contingent thing on this
revelation of Truth and all these terms
I know I'm just like covering my I'm
face palming saying them all but you
know it's it's his his version of the
subject is this one created by the that
pays Fidelity to it it doesn't pre-exist
but it exists afterwards only by
committing to the Act and the act of
Revolution not political revolution But
whichever kind of Revolution yeah it
could include stuff like uh like um
scientific revolutions right the scci
the Scientific
Revolution St Paul was a was a subject
of Christianity paradigms yeah
so I mean this is this sounds very cool
when when he's talking about communism
or something like that the the subject
of the event of Communism we don't
really have the event we haven't seen it
yet or we saw some but they weren't the
ones that we wanted to continue but we
may see the next one so the subject is
produced by that event and that's his
response to a leanian subject which is
nothing right it comes from below the
count it comes from non-existence and
then it suddenly it suddenly exists by
putting faith into the event this is
like a revolutionary vision of the
proletariat that there's nobody and then
suddenly there are subjects so I don't
know like this isn't my style I can say
but I can see why it's like cool yeah
and it it helps sort of answer that
question of of Eternal Truth versus the
obvious fact that you know know the
present is now and the here and now so
how how does one relate to these sort of
enduring truths about the world that
philosophy supposedly gives us and then
where's the room for the revolution in
in that sort of picture of the universe
of of Eternal and enduring laws that we
can make true statements about but then
it's not going to tell us anything about
this contingent life world of ours
it's just going to tell us sort of what
to expect as a kind of pattern sure but
yeah I mean I can see this gesture as
almost being very you know philosophy as
therapy or iatric versus philosophy as
what we would sort of think of more
narrowly as science I think a good
example is that the the truth when it
emerges becomes Eternal which is not to
say that it's Eternal extending
indefinitely into the past but if you
think of something like the liberal
subject like Hobs lock very liberal
subject the individual in the terms that
we use it today like the individual
never existed there's no and we still
know there's not really such thing as an
individual because an individual means
an atom something that can't be split
something that doesn't have an
unconscious something that is only
itself forever but the liberal
Revolution created this so that we can
only view all of history in terms of the
individual like why the hell was this
Egyptian laborer building the pyramids
when he wasn't going to go to heaven and
his his master was that wouldn't have
been a question so part of what truth
does is produce questions that would
have been unas or uh they couldn't be
they wouldn't be possible that these
revolutions happen and they change the
entire notion of what history was
previously which is I guess another
interesting way of talking about it I'm
not I didn't encounter bad fully and
early on philosophy's purpose in some
sense is then to you're going to
encounter these
sutures that try to reduce the
conditions of Truth to something else
whether it's uh politics like haiger did
this in his mind haiger sutured his
politics to or sutured his philosophy to
politics ICS which is a kind of simple
handwavy example of why he became a Nazi
because he forgot his he forgot his
position as philosopher which is
commitment to truth
procedures now B Bia spends a lot of
time highlighting Vicken Stein's sort of
confessional side too he's got this
confessional side where he writes in his
journal about religion and Christianity
and
um and becoming a becoming like a priest
and he has these
questions right it's interesting part of
anti philosophy is this sort of
self-questioning and he mentions early
on one of the characteristics
exemplified by nche is is seeing kind of
the
priests sort of behind the
scenes of the
truth right the priests who encourage
nihilism and benefit from it and it's
almost like a a kind of again like a
kind of skepticism those like a master
of Suspicion type of thing I I sort of
thought of anti-philosophy almost as an
as an extension of that as well these
masters of Suspicion I I'd say relative
to the other uh you know calls for
renewal of philosophy or whatever
Humanities that we've read this gives
the
philosopher a very specific place and
it's not a very large place and it's not
a very important place which I kind of
like but the philosopher in this sense
becomes a sort of
technician who has a certain disposition
towards the objective world and the
world objective world I mean as like a a
a settled state of bodies and languages
in his terms but the world in general
like the world of people and the world
of [__] happening doesn't really need
philosophy at all right because most
people don't need philosophy either it's
a particular
disposition and the the other broad
calls for returning to the true call of
philosophy this is romantic at best and
just really [__] stupid at worst but
he's kind of uh defining the parameters
specifically enough to
say I as a philosopher have one job here
it is it's to identify the truth
procedures of a certain event what comes
from the event what doesn't come from
the event and then in the process I have
to deal with anti-philosophy this this
this group of really intelligent really
noteworthy adversaries that I have to uh
combat with in order to Define my
position as a positing philosopher and I
do kind of like that I think it it gives
one of the mo most reasonable calls for
for philosophy that I've because
philosophy now is everything philosophy
is like your brand or your disposition
towards life or um Theory what we call
Theory this is like sometimes called
philosophy and for good reason I think
we call it something else but uh he
gives a very he gives very particular
parameters for what this activity is
supposed to do which I kind of find
refreshing in the sense that it's uh
humble
I don't know if it's accurate I really
can't say because you you'd have to buy
into all the terminology but it's at
least humble and specific I feel like
what Vicken Stein does for him is shows
the kind of emptiness of the linguistic
turn
and kind of uses the linguistic turn as
a way of completely deflating
philosophy and sort of taking out its
search for truth kind of taking out or
like almost like flipping the conditions
of that search for truth that there's no
truth in
language that language only speaks facts
but facts are not sort of in language
their sense is in the world and so it
sort of questions philosophy's ability
to capture truths yeah because if they
speak Eternal truths states of Affairs
but you know the world is contingent
then in order to be true something has
to be both Eternal but then it has to be
verified as
actually have actually
happening so there's truth and
contingency are so close and this is one
of the very few critiques of Dera that I
will actually accept because almost all
the time when people are shit-talking
Dara it's you know truth Everything's
Relative forget all that which isn't
what he was doing of course but what
Badu is saying he did is actually what
he did which is I'm not going to pay
attention to that stuff I'm not going to
assume that it is I'm going to pay
attention to the way in which linguistic
truths are performed by supplements and
Alibi and the way that language is used
in philosophy and I'm going to give up
on that Search for universal truth
because that's not what I'm interested
in but Badu's criticism of Dara as an
anti- philosopher is actually correct
that he gave up on those things but do
is saying I'm going to accept dar but I
want to be able to also get out of that
to get to somewhere else now personally
that's somewhere else is not somewhere
that I care to be or I don't care about
any of this terminology or any of this
stuff because I'm a anti philosopher but
it's actually an accurate criticism for
once which is you know relieving thank
God yeah I mean it working with all
these you know working as a logical
positivist seems kind of
anti-philosophical
in itself and it's kind of interesting
that this sort of densely philosophical
book by Vicken Stein is is you know like
Vicken Stein is like an analytic
philosopher you can take entire courses
on versus if you want to learn other
things about analytic philosophy it's
usually just kind of topic based which
is kind of unique for an analytic
philosopher who you just expect to be
kind of dry using symbolic logic to tell
you about you know the condition you're
learning truth tables condition of true
statements but here it has a
really philosophical yeah like in the
proper sense kind of thrust to that
whole Dow
Enterprise as Vicken Stein is is kind of
fascinating in that way language only
speaks kind of nonsense right like the
linguistic sphere of nonsense is just
cloaked in sense it kind of brings you
up into contact with the
nonsense and it takes a lot of very
careful brilliant thinking to do that
you know so learning like I I just like
it because it's like B is showing you
this this way of
being anti- philosophy almost radical
philosophy and dealing with set theory
and logic and and things you would
consider more instrumental and not
geared for these kinds of purposes but
they certainly are I'm convinced anyway
by but you I like it I like it I can't
help getting triggered from all of my
memories of the
analytical courses that I had to take
because yeah that's super fun if you're
interested in professionally solving
sidoku puzzles or figuring out if
there's a hologram of a cat inside a
room with no windows and yet a boltzman
brain appears in the room with no
windows with the Hologram of a cat who's
on a hologram of a mat do you have
Justified true belief well I mean that's
I mean those tools with some of the more
broad purposes and goals of Continental
philosophy right like rarely does
analytic philosophy have such Grand aims
as Vicken Stein like to show that the
you know yeah that that philos
philosophical problems are really just
problems with the way we understand
language and so he's going to solve
those problems in that way I mean that's
very def aary of
Truth and it's an interesting challenge
right like an analytic philosopher
wouldn't normally be worried by such
results they would just sort of go along
with the idea that yeah truth is sort of
guaranteed it's not here that concern
shines forth even with all the dense
technical stuff it kind of gives me hope
it's like complicated philosophy and it
can still have an air of
rigor truth being like a precondition
that if we get the right description
then going to arrive at it is very
different from uh
Badu's version of the truth being
something that is confirmed as having
been but after the fact which is kind of
radical do you think though there's like
there's something to be taken from the
linguistic turn that he's not taking
like he's calling truth something that
no one's really called it before he's
kind of making it up where do you get
the
authority in terms of like a an AR where
do you get the authority to be able to
do that and just call it philosophy is
there a slide of hand there do you think
well he calls he calls what Vicken
Stein's doing Arch athetic the the
Aristotle's definition of Truth is just
to say what is as it is it's like pretty
simple if you have a representation that
coin coincides with the actual State of
Affairs then you're speaking truth and
otherwise you're speaking a lie but this
ver version of Truth as
being uh Fidelity paid to an
event that produces discourse isn't that
just redefining well I think the the
truth yeah the truth is the unsayable
and so what what is so he's you know
taking away he's challenging this
boundary between the sayable and the
unsayable and what is thinkable and
what's Unthinkable can't what is it that
that of which we cannot speak we must
remain silent right so what is sayable
in terms of you know propositions and
statements conveying facts but the true
part is the unsayable which is
aesthetic yeah like philosophy is out of
step with the conditions of truth if
it's going to be all about what is
sayable but does he defeat it from their
persp their perspective I'm I'm making
more of a metac critique here if you
take truth and try to make it self
reference IAL in the way that it's used
here is he trying to make an event out
of truth that is then also true because
clearly Aristotle's logic is not good
enough for him which is why it needs to
be replaced but Truth for him then has
to be true which would track
self-referentially because in his mind
he is being faithful to his definition
however if you're going to take the
linguistic antiphilosophy
Vicken Stein Dara at its sense making
you actually haven't overcome their
critique from that point of reference
have you because by redefining the
central tenant of
philosophy uh logic and logical
deductions as true couldn't it just as
easy easily be said that he's yet
extending or playing a new language game
and no more than
that I don't know it's worth it's worth
considering
uh but because we're personal question
Eric if we have all this considered and
you have to pick
aide at the end of this are you going to
be on team philosophy or team
anti-philosophy I think I think probably
philosopher still but with with anti
philosop I wouldn't
want to be without anti-
philosophy but I wouldn't want there to
only be anti philosophy either
it seems one like one is one is you know
almost you know almost like the
connotational the ideological and the
other one is like the aesthetic the the
metalinguistic like in Bar's terms one
of them is totalizing and the other
one's DET totalizing and they're
complimentary one of them is life and
movement why I I feel like I always fall
into the the Philo philosophical mode by
returning to Arguments for things like
correctness for things like accuracy for
um hermeneutic context but I think yeah
when you line up all the anti-
philosophers I'm like dope but they
wouldn't exist without the philosopher
having posited in the first place yeah I
think they are like necessary but also
kind of dependent because you wouldn't
want to just read about you
know positively affirming the truth pure
affirm
all day because sometimes
it's sometimes you just want to be
[__] pessimistic sometimes you want
to play yeah like I think he would be
very opposed to uh a bardian thesis of
this just all being a game the stakes
seem rather higher for him it's not a
game it's very serious we must pay
Fidelity to the event so it's like the
deflation of Truth isn't final it's
something it's a challenge to
philosophy otherwise philosophy would
just sort of go on all puffed up over
its own successes and and
never and never
question and never question its basic
motivations and the dialogue continues
so there we go anti philosophy sorry for
the difficult episode if it was hope you
uh got something out of it in any case
so I will see you guys later and
listeners talk at you talk at you next
time bye
[Music]
wow